hi, ich bin Carolina
ähm und ich hab
Gemeinschaftskunde LK und deshalb fand ich's echt
interessant hier einfach noch mal bisschen
Hintergrundinformation zu bekommen
und deshalb hab ich heute mitgemacht.
ich bin die Michaela.
ich hab zwar kein Gemeinschaftskunde Ek,
aber es hat mich trotz.
also allgemein so Politik für mich spannend
und da dacht ich Mir so,
boah ja ich darf dieses Jahr wählen,
dann hätt ich gern n paar Infos dazu allgemein wie das
abgeht und so ähm
also ich wollte einfach noch n paar
Hintergrundinformationen,
weil ich nich so viel über das Thema wusste
ähm und das war so eigentlich meine größte Hoffnung.
genau da geht's Mir wie Carolina
einfach so n bisschen mehr Klarheit zu allem,
weil es is schon auch echt n großes
komplexes Thema und einfach so
mehr Infos dazu,
dass es einfach
logischer wird was da nich abgeht.